okay here are some questions Jennifer do
you think that as president Hillary
would be likely to reach across the
aisle to fill positions in her
administration
absolutely absolutely what she did in
the Senate it's what she's intending to
do she wants to make sure that she can
demonstrate that she can you know create
opportunity to bring sides together she
will absolutely do that you don't my
problem without though is that the
Democrats have this habit of filling
security positions with Republicans and
it just makes people think yeah they're
the daddy party they kick take care of
[ __ ] I'm a Democrat too you know you
know you know I'm serious about the CIA
IRA I appointed a Republican head it
homee a head of the FBI appointed by
Obama nothing went wrong there huh no
don't assume though that she would do
that traditional thing she's gonna fill
half of her cabinet with women she's
gonna have a cabinet that looks like
America and and America has some
Republicans in it too so she has
probably and some sane ones yes exactly
yeah but they won't all just be in the I
don't think in the security you're
Justin Trudeau filled half his cabinet
with women and they asked him why is it
because it was 2016 right I mean most of
the world the civilized world does that
already a lot way down we are so like
percentage of women in government
America is like 80th why is it that we
don't have access to affordable
childcare it's because we have not had
women in sufficient numbers in
leadership why is it that we don't have
parental leave that's paid we're the
only industrialized nation that doesn't
because we have not had women and I say
parental leave because men should have
the opportunity to choose to stay home
too I think people are under estimating
the sexism that still out there okay I
really do I take a look you know I don't
know if this would be happening the same
way to a man can you imagine people yeah
I mean that I mean there was a Trump was
out there yesterday speaking in front of
a bunch of admirals and generals who
were for him and he said you know you
think these people want her to be the
boss what hurt her to be the boss and
like all his white men
you know some of whom have had a woman
boss and didn't like it that really boy
you're gonna run out to the voting
they're even talking about her her voice
or her outfit right I know her voice how
about his voice right that's mom when he
goes soft it's a disaster okay it would
have take up one thing a pine shovel
right least okay oh he's so disgusting
and can you can you imagine if a 69 year
old woman right three times married had
five children from three different
spouses had talked about groping a
male's genital road had can you imagine
how is show woman your own cow she's a
four or five yeah
can't even that up says so much about
the sexes that you can't even think of a
woman like that now he wanted to make
the joke who would you say would what
what you never knew Lucy so true did you
you didn't know Lou why hasn't the media
covered the woman suing Trump for
accusations from a thirteen-year-old
that she was raped by Donald Trump okay
[Music]
okay and she's here tonight yeah feeling
a lot better about it
uh no but because because of the same
editorial standards that you demand
because they don't know who he said he
has no editorial standards it's
interesting for people who don't know
this by the way let me just explain
there is a woman who says in the 90s she
was at parties with Jeffrey Epstein
Jeffrey Epstein is a convicted child
predator right Bill Clinton was on his
plane he's a billionaire okay doesn't
mean he was doing anything but Prince
Andrew was on the play lots of it that's
been in the news a lot
look I waited let me just you explain it
for people who don't know the story
Jeffrey Epstein Trump is on record
saying I love Jeffrey Epstein great guy
hang around with him he loves beautiful
women like I do and he likes him young
you know he this is on record mm-hmm so
okay this is from the 90s the statute of
limitation should the woman won't come
forward
she has canceled several press coverage
she thinks she's gonna come forward and
then she doesn't follow this so there's
no she filed the suit but she's just a
Jane Doe there's no person there so the
press can't so I'm not saying it's true
it's an old story but it is interesting
that I mean we know he is a sexual
predator of Cabot type and he admits
that he likes young girls and you know
you can like the young girls over the
age and of legal age and that's fine but
this woman was underage at the time and
I don't know you hear this story as you
don't go that's impossible it's not like
she's saying I'm it's one date rape
there wasn't a question about Donald
Trump it was a question about the media
I don't take any of you on her story it
could well be true you know I think
there are many of the stories that have
come forward and they have looked like
they're true
question is why don't responsible media
organizations act on a story when they
don't know who brought it forward when
they have no way of verifying it and
that is responsible behavior and that's
the kind of thing we need to defend and
affirm and not to criticize it should be
responsible behavior on the part of the
candidates and riles and that's the
problem he has none yes he's gotten it
this was the other way he'd be up there
on the hustling just saying it as if it
was he'll say anything people's people
are saying this and there's pretty soon
rush the people are saying yes this says
the Harriman's
but but what kills me is that these
respectable news organizations have
things like fact checkers which are
objective entities that check statements
on the part of candidates and they've
checked Hillary Clinton statements and
they've checked his statements 70% of
the statements that he utters are lies
yes seven and yes and yet again an
indictment of the media more people
think she well because he trusts he
keeps calling her that right no she is
adjusted to the surrogate you have to
saying one view and to the other and
Kellyanne Conway is a false equivalence
hi Anson you know I you I judge me and
say I mean you just you so it's
everything's equal you walk away from
that even if you're you say well then I
guess the two sides again it's not two
separate organizations have behaved in
different ways maybe the term the media
isn't helpful because how do you know
that Donald Trump statements are untrue
who is doing the work of finding out
that they're not true well it is it's
easy to find out today you know nobody
not fact checkers he says things like
Hillary Clinton wants to repeal the
Second Amendment yeah and there's no
Hillary Clinton statement ever say
anything like that
that's called a lie how do you know
about his taxes people did the hard work
to fight to find it out if the public
doesn't believe them as you said in your
interview with the president that's on
them now there are cable news
organizations and here I'll agree with
you that have not behaved well and the
demand that the demand to say you know
we uh we're going to we want to turn
every discussion into a Punch and Judy
show
and if punch turns out to be Charles
Manson then we're going to find some Pro
Charles Manson punches to defend him now
that was that is something that I think
after the season is over
some cable networks are gonna have to
rethink why did they feel the need to
have absolutely some people who had no
conservative credentials we wanted a
balance between a Republican and a
Democrat the whole point was the
organized Republican Party largely
rejected him so you went out and
invented all of these Republicans of
whom no one had ever heard 15 minutes
before or to the extent they were heard
of that regarded as munot ticks or
Dumbo's and there they are because who
no one else would do the job the cable
fill the part of the cable network
wanted to assign that's on that network
but when you when you go on when you go
on this when you say why why is the
public not believing what newspapers
have gone to bed terribly under people
it paid people david Farenthold at the
Washington Post who were like line by
line check when he couldn't get the
records on Trump's charities would call
the charities would think of every
charity could think of the Donald Trump
might have ever given to and caught I
think he ended up calling more than 400
charities right that was one person who
I think has not no research assistance
and he you know does probably doesn't
make as much as Donald Trump's makeup
artist and and he did that work and when
you when you attack the media you're
attacking him and that's not right no
and yes here's a naive here's a naive
thought not understand the main point
Dave that the media should be defended
because we're attacking them yes there
are good people in the meeting your
institution is impossible using media is
different than print media you're right
print media the few institutions that we
still have to do the job
three cheers for them unfortunately no
one [ __ ] reads them anymore they
watch television or they get it on their
phone or they don't know anything they
just hear it from people truck I said if
a man by phone and can say that a person
is gonna let in 650 million people in a
week and America just goes huh I'm not
I'm not here to defend my industry in
particular I'm here to defend all the
Constitution's make American our
question wonders so my question short
last line I know I'm just saying this in
my fantasy after World War one we had
the League of Nations after World War
Two we got the United Nations this has
been like a world war what we have gone
through this election can all the
network's not go on a retreat and make
an agreement of honesty to present
information to the public that are dying
to know the truth because why would cost
them money because it's a race to the
bottom to get what if there was a fine
for every report of lie well that's not
it's in it it's in their interest to
make it close I mean Hillary is talking
about so many issues and they'd ignore
it I talk about emails they talk about
emails I mean today emails are on the
print the emails are important okay Dave
right on your behind
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]